well it's nice it's always nice to enter
room knowing that time it the folks
outside are raving about you oh no
pressure
just sit yeah you better live up okay
I'm going to focus really hard on it
well first of all I have to say I walked
away from the films with like one major
question okay
King Kong murder is knowing a romantic
leading man oh I mean isn't that the
question right yeah I think I know
Mason's master God well of course I love
him
yeah I think he's an angel yeah it had
true that when you were when you had
your first interaction with him and I
know of course it's it's a CG effect but
you were thinking about the first time
you had a connection with an elephant
yeah yeah so what per limit ears huh
because it's really and it's a powerful
moment to experience and I don't know
how many people in the world have
experienced this but when I got to like
touch an elephant
I felt so conflicted by it because you
just know that this thing is so powerful
and it can just like crush you
immediately and so there's a sense of
like this thing could take me down right
now but it's not there's this deep
gentleness and and so it really stuck
with me I thought I felt like to be a
really powerful experience and that's
how I imagined it would be like to touch
calm yeah absolutely I think that in our
film she's the only person on the island
that that is willing to listen to him
and is willing to understand him and not
use force when she's the only character
that doesn't have a weapon true she
never she never puts down her camera for
a gun mm-hmm yeah and I think that he
understands that and they share this
moment that's like very clear that
obviously she's not going to hurt him
yeah so he's willing to go the extra
mile for her sure you're rolling with a
lot of boys in this picture I'm guessing
a little tomboy side to you you see my
head at home with the dude I'm amazed
that I've like suppress my tomboy nature
for this long I'm way more comfortable
and Jesus a t-shirt running around that
I am in a dress but I'm glad that I've
been able to like keep that on the DL
for a while yeah
well now you know you can you can go
both ways on that on that front yes I
have to ask you yourself Tom and familar
all off to the next adventures in the
Marvel Universe are you straight to it
what's the plan all I can't say they're
all top secret which are you working on
it yep it's top secret come on you're
the captain you can divulge it no that's
why I must keep it dipped
well the world is definitely looking
forward to seeing you in that Amell I
know I definitely am thank you so much
yeah I think you a pleasure to meet you